boulet cavs show we got a special guest
about to do it stay we haven't done a
freestyle with joe moses it says it was
me and dj head hanging out at real 923
like four years ago yeah it's been a
while yeah you've been kind of man just
doing everything else while working on
music yeah facts building up this
football [ __ ] yeah building up these new
businesses building up this new sneaker
oh yeah
let's uh let's shout out the shoes man
coaching
that's cote he said i could wear these
you can wear them anywhere you want it
and wear those in your hood well my kids
you could okay i just wanna make sure
because i know it might not be the right
color no man you could wear it with my
hood you could wear it with your hood he
said you look like a white guy you'll be
all right
now you're gonna be all right peer with
me there it is we ain't doing that hey
well look let's just get right to the
work man
hey
hey raised with jamaica's like bz and mr
b after 54 they do it for gold like mr t
you could call the ogs and they'll tell
you i'm the g had the rock like jay but
i'm so in love with the bee should i
come from the streets what killing is
only peace don't wanna be food then
[ __ ] you better eat well homicidal turn
you to a killer now a beast i'm just
trying to be a legend like pops in big d
with brick moe had the roman big goat he
had caprice and baby bone had the
trapping big ham road ds should i come
from the bottom where we don't do police
and it's anybody k we like elo man op we
just waiting on these feasts honey blood
we a bleed i'm trying to build a legacy
i'm like apollo with the creed will your
mama go crazy so that kid she got a feed
in the streets there's no dad so your
mama gotta teach and your homies ain't
your homie so that love you don't need
they say put it in the book and watch
these [ __ ] won't read should i come
from the struggle with killing this od i
been stabbed in the back now i'm dying
to slow leak and they all on my dick
like moby i'm low key a real [ __ ] like
toby these crackers can't hold me big
nuts on your [ __ ] i tell her to hold
these only positive vibe negative i
don't need segregation so ease gotcha
plate now for the g's she just wanna
give me [ __ ] i only want it if they
threes and i'm only throwing bees like i
signed with 23 and i'm shooting at their
head like they shooting at 23 and the
birds is 23 so you can get it for 23.
it's 24 hours in the day and i'm just
sitting for 23. see i started with a six
but i changed it like 23 i get my king
james on move to cali for the piece and
i'm still low keeper west coast is on me
i'm a legend with the d like punchy and
big meets and since i'm speaking on the
real i gotta save free meech she just
looking for my paper she can never get
the d i'm just going no limit i'm just
mastering my piece i'm just dotting on
my eyes and i'm crossing on my teeth
sometimes my diamonds look like water
sometimes my diamonds look like sneeze
by the way the lebron line is crazy oh
yeah
yeah
come on man joe moses the new album
comes out on the 30th of september on
the 30th yeah
go run that [ __ ] up i know you just
watched a crazy freestyle we got another
one coming next week presented to you by
lrg don't forget to use my promo code at
l-r-g.com
go to their website it's in the
description below
and use the promo code bootleg you'll
save 30 off and they just drop these
look at these basketball shorts boys
these things is crazy you know what i'm
saying lrg's [ __ ] back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you some 30 off right now